well hi I'm Kate hollenbach and I'm a
media artist and programmer and this is
an artist talk about a series of works
that I made with software that I
developed to record myself while I was
using my phone this is also my first
in-person talk at a conference since
2020 and my first time at strange Loop
so I'm really excited to be here
foreign
[Applause]
thanks that just really charged me up uh
this talk is called Art you can make by
spying on yourself with your phone and
maybe should have been more accurately
called Art that I made by spying on
myself with my phone uh as I'll be more
focused on showing you what the projects
were rather than how they were made so
my work addresses uh the tensions of
interface design data collection and new
sensing Technologies and I'm enthralled
by new technologies that expand the
expressive capabilities of computers I
believe in the computer as an expressive
tool and software as an expressive
medium but I'm also worried about some
things I'm worried about the growing
amount of data that is collected and
processed in the service of user
experience and other intents
so to give you some context for this
talk I'll tell you a little bit about my
background currently I am an assistant
professor in the emergent digital
practices program at University of
Denver where I teach art and creative
coding classes as well as technology and
culture classes for both undergraduate
and graduate students so if there are
any of you in the audience who think
they want to spend two to three years in
art school I would love to talk to you
afterward and I'm also on the board of
directors for the processing Foundation
which supports the development of Open
Source tools for Creative coders like
processing in p5.js
and for me thanks uh for me working with
code uh is an avid Avenue for a
critically examining technology and
making creative work
in a past life I worked as a user
interface designer and programmer uh as
oblong Industries director of design and
computation before I joined Academia and
at oblong I worked with an
interdisciplinary team of designers and
programmers to build gestural interfaces
and Conference Room collaboration
products like mezzanine which is
pictured uh in this slide
and after working in the software
industry for a while I started to wonder
about what would happen if I were able
to make some time to focus on personal
work and so I went back to graduate
school at UCLA where I just studied
design media arts and more recently I've
been making work about phones gestures
and surveillance which is what most of
this talk will focus on
so some guiding questions for my
practice are what happens as computers
know and learn more about human bodies
what freedoms and privacies are
jeopardized or lost altogether and how
do human bodies change under the
pressures of emerged virtual and
physical reality and as a disclaimer I
won't really answer these questions in
the talk but they're what I think about
when I'm making work
so when I went to graduate school it
really re-situated my expectations for
how you use mobile devices and how and
when it's appropriate to use a mobile
device so surely I had seen some uh and
used mine in meetings at work and
multitasked like to do things like
checking email during meetings or other
secondary activities but for some reason
I failed to expect that that would also
be true in a university setting and I
couldn't believe that people were just
checking Instagram during class and this
is because I hadn't been in school when
the iPhone became widely adopted so this
change of context for me from going to
Industry and back to school kind of took
mobile devices and made them like
conspicuous to me again and made them
strange to me so I really really
couldn't get them off my mind
and relatedly Wendy Chun writes that
habits are strange contradictory things
they are human-made nature or more
broadly culture becomes second nature
there are practices acquired through
time that are seemingly forgotten as
they move from the voluntary to the
involuntary the conscious to the
automatic and as they do so they
penetrate and define a person a body and
a grouping of bodies
so I was interested in thinking about
the habits formed around mobile phones
and I made a few Works around this topic
including this work here at infinite
scroll and this is an installation that
considers scrolling as a habit in this
project I asked nine friends to scroll
through their Facebook and Twitter feeds
and took a screen capture of each one of
those and then I wrote a really crude
computer vision application in a
platform called Cinder to convert the
posts into blocks of color
so the installation plays each of the
videos on a continuous loop and the
phones are mounted on the wall in a
cluster above eye level forcing the user
to look up at them and admire them
so here it is in motion
and you can see the different speeds and
habits of each user so generally the
motion is upward because that's the
direction or scrolling but occasionally
you see a pause or a downward motion
where people are going going back to see
something that they may be passed over a
little quickly
and as an installation I was also
interested in what role the phone plays
in documentation or the experience of
the work and how it lives online
I'm also really interested in the
language that's used to describe
technology so this is a piece I made
around the same time that's a web-based
project called revolutionary devices and
this project is still up at
revolutionarydevices.com it's a website
that endlessly generates new mobile
phone designs until the user closes the
tab or the browser crashes the page
because it's showing too many images
uh so some of the designs are strange
but most of them are are pretty similar
to today's uh devices and so this is a
play on the language that gets used to
describe uh even mundane updates to
technology projects
uh but the smartphone is something that
I think probably most of us would no
longer consider revolutionary these days
it's more of a commodity and as a
technology becomes a commodity it
becomes kind of unremarkable which is
when it can also become dangerous so
let's talk a little bit about the
progression of user input devices for a
computer and how they see model and
Abstract human bodies
so from the computer's perspective the
mouse reduces your entire body to a
single Cartesian XY Point uh in space
with an on off switch maybe a couple if
you have a fancier Mouse right so ones
or zeros for buttons
and newer devices like depth sensors can
track more information about our bodies
and how they move through a
three-dimensional space which gives lots
of opportunities for new types of
interfaces and these types of devices
also can help a computer understand
things like when a person waves their
hand
so depth sensors see a skeleton view of
the body it's much more detailed than
the single point that the mouse
describes the body as but it's still a
relatively simple model so there are
some key joints for the limbs the Torso
and the head Etc
mobile devices add several other layers
they have multiple data layers so some
of these things are sensors like GPS
that can say where you are or motion
sensors that know that the device is
moving and probably you are too or
things like microphones so you can
actually call someone because it is
still a phone at the end of the day and
importantly there's also a high
resolution camera on both the front and
back of the device
so each of these uh types of sensors
reveal more information about our bodies
and for me the camera is of particular
interest because it can be used to
describe uh and analyze our facial
expressions and head movements in the
service of interface design and this
gives rise to a lot of new really
exciting and convenient features like
being able to unlock your phone with
your face
uh but I've also found myself really
fascinated with the phone as a device
that For Better or Worse sees a lot of
its user and shapes the habits of its
user so the smartphone is usually a
private display but often visible in a
public space like this one and a
one-to-one relationship between a person
and the device exists so usually there
aren't multiple users for a phone like
there might be for a desktop computer
and so even if you don't talk to your
digital assistant like as a person an
emotional connection often still exists
between a user and the device and
throughout the day the user gazes at the
phone so does the phone gaze back what
if it did what does it see what does it
understand and what is at stake
so exploring these questions as an
artist who works with technology I
wanted to develop some software to
automate some video capture from my
phone
so I was curious about what patterns or
habits might become visible if I could
see what my phone saw
so I started working on an Android app
that I called phone loves you too that
would
automatically record a video from the
front and back cameras every time the
device was unlocked
and initially I thought I'd use this to
make something like a feature film using
footage from a single day and while the
footage from a single day didn't really
seem that interesting on its own I
thought I might find something
interesting if I kept recording for a
while and it was kind of hard to build
the app so I thought I really want to
see this through and see if anything can
come out of this so I recorded for a
whole month 31 days and at the end of
the month I had about 1100 video clips
with anywhere from 30 to 90 minutes of
footage per day and this also meant that
it was too much to watch and figure out
what to do with it all but I really
wanted to see it all so at school I was
lucky to have access to this amazing
space which had five projectors
installed in an immersive environment so
I decided I would find out what the
resolution was for that super projector
and lay out all the clips to watch
simultaneously which results in the work
that you see here
so the clips are arranged uh in the
order that they were captured left to
right across the space some of them are
really short lasting only a few seconds
and some of them are up to an hour most
of the videos are on the shorter side
just from activities like quickly
checking social media or answering a
text message and the longer videos came
from activities like reading an article
maybe from start to finish which for me
doesn't happen that often on my phone
but uh the longest activity is by far or
when I would have the GPS on my phone
and I lived in Los Angeles at the time
so sometimes if you have to cross down
during rush hour you might be using the
GPS for like an entire hour right
so this was the initial set of clips
that I had
and here's a close-up from uh one
section of the video so it shows a lot
of intimate moments that I wouldn't
otherwise share with other people and uh
some of those activities include I'm
gonna see if I can get my mouse over
here great
uh so some of these activities include
things like eating
down here in the bottom right hand
corner
uh in this one uh my cat is trying to
snuggle with me in the morning in some
of these in the top left here I'm
actually in the car and then perhaps
walking from class or some errand and
then going back to the car uh and the my
favorite actual sequence in this project
is what's in the bottom left hand corner
here which is uh me getting my hair dyed
so I'm sitting under one of those like
dryers uh trying to wait for the bleach
to set in
and so when I shared this with my
classmates at grad school one of them
was kind of upset uh and said that the
person in the videos didn't really look
like me because it didn't really capture
any of my personality it was really just
me staring blankly at the phone and it
didn't have any of the normal like
friendly affectations that I would have
if you're talking to me directly and I
thought maybe that they also said this
because they had never seen me without
makeup on before uh which
accounted for most of the clips that
were in this project because a lot of
them uh were from when I was at home
and also if you're wondering uh yes did
uh did the app really change the way
that I used my phone it really did
um at this time and I allowed this to
happen so it was really hard to tell
what felt like it was authentic and what
didn't I did not try to perform for the
camera but there were some things where
I would catch myself wondering would I
do this if I wasn't recording or
do I not want to do this because I'm
recording and is that okay and do I know
now am I thinking too hard about it
should I stop doing it anyway or
whatever uh but I did use my phone a lot
less during this time which in some ways
was really good for me but in other ways
I had turned turned my phone into this
uh awful kind of recording device so
that had its own uh things with it and
the other major uh change was that I
rarely ever took my phone into the
bathroom during this specific period of
time
uh and here's the same project installed
in another location at the San Francisco
museum of modern modern art and so the
work was up for about three months there
and I had an opportunity to watch people
take their own posed selfies in front of
the work and sometimes they'd find me on
Instagram and actually tag me in these
selfies uh or mention me which was uh
really special and while it seems like
the project is really exposing and it is
um because all of these videos are
playing back simultaneously it's also
really dizzying and so it feels like
it's also a place to hide it's hard to
focus on any one clip because it's
something else in the corner always
catches your eye so it felt like in some
ways uh this was like hiding in a
crowded public space and I wanted to see
if I could
change what the feeling of exposure was
like by arranging the Clips in a
different way so after I finished this
iteration of the project I immediately
began thinking about how else I might
compose the 31 days of video clips and
how I might incorporate all of the
footage from the back camera which I had
also recorded but not yet used
so the next work that I came up with
looks something like this in an effort
to see more of the clips or to be able
to focus on them better I remixed the
footage into a long form video piece
lasting 24 hours and in the piece both
the front and back camera videos are
displayed side by side and arranged in a
calendar grid
so the clips are played at the time that
they were recorded So if you go to The
Gallery at 3 30 in the afternoon you
would see clips that were recorded at 3
30 in the afternoon and only those clips
and if you wanted to see the ones that
were from 10 AM well you'd have to come
back the next day at 10 A.M so there are
some problems with showing this work uh
and then the other detail is that when a
clip ends it leaves behind the last
frame as a trace so you still get to see
some hint of what the other activity was
so at 7 30 in the morning maybe there
will be three clips playing so these
areas would be brighter and moving
or at 6 45 there might even be more
and unlike the previous work the results
of this work feel very slow paced so
instead of anxiety or an overwhelming
feeling coming from the flurry of
activity uh in the volume of the videos
it comes from wondering when the next
clip might appear or when it might go
live and to heighten this I added the
sound of a phone unlocking when each
clip would start and the lock sound when
the um
clip would end so that people would
think about their own devices too so
here are some stills from various times
of day this is around 9 15 in the
morning
and this is around 10 in the morning
not an uncommon time for me to be in the
car I guess
and 11 15
around noon
and around 8 30 at night and generally
in the evenings there were less Clips
because I would be busy with other
people around and not in my phone as
much or as the morning hours tended to
have a lot more activity
and here's uh one around midnight
so here's a clip of the video around 7
45 in the morning
which was apparently a very common time
for me to wake up while I was in
graduate school
and very quietly from my computer I can
hear the unlock sound playing
[Laughter]
laughs
cat is very cuddly
and as soon as she hears the alarm goes
off she wants me to know she's available
so looking at both of these works and
reflecting on them I felt that they both
contained a sort of inherent judgment
that maybe the phone is pulling us out
of physical space and overwhelming our
senses
and the reality is our reality is more
complex than that our lives are both
simultaneously online and offline so the
videos I felt were a little misleading
because they make it look like nothing's
happening but really all the action at
these times is on the device itself
so from here I worked on a new version
of the software that would also capture
the screen to see if that would present
a more complete picture of the
activities that were taking place and
while working on previous versions of
the project I learned a lot about video
encoding and uh was able to capture
higher resolution video to work in this
iterate to use in this next iteration of
the project and this time I also had a
visual style in mind for combining all
three of the video feeds
so here's a different idea of what
waking up in the morning is like
and there's a lot of sensitive
information here it feels really
intimate to see the names of people in
my inbox and Instagram feed while I'm in
bed some of these people are close
friends but a lot of them are not
and then there's also some parts where
I'm filling in personal information like
at this time I was for health reasons I
was tracking my weight
and this iteration of the work is called
user is present and it Blends the front
and back camera footage together with
the screen capture using a really really
simple glsl Shader
so here's another uh
version where I am actually talking to
other people during this clip and
looking at Instagram at the same time
and here's another one where I am
waiting for the elevator at school and
can't just wait without doing something
so good opportunity to check email or
see what's going on on Instagram
and while both of the previous projects
I showed you had focused on me as a
subject I considered that more of a
convenience than a goal for the project
it was easy to use myself as a project
as the subject
but after running some initial tests uh
myself with the screen capture version
of the software it felt like time to
expand the work and to get some other
people involved so I asked two very very
good and very trusting friends who were
familiar with my practice and knew what
they were getting into uh to participate
and so the result was an installation
with three video portraits showed on a
large display with the same proportions
that a phone screen would have and for
this iteration of the project like I
said I had also figured out how to
capture the video a little bit more
efficiently so the coding was better and
I was able to actually get a resolution
that was good enough to look on the
screen
or to look at on screen and each video
uh for each portrait was a different
like which meant that when people came
back to see the installation at
different times or if they watched it
for a while they would see different
juxtapositions of activities so
sometimes things would be very similar
across all three portraits or sometimes
they would be really different
so here are some Stills looking a little
bit different as before there are some
like awkward moments like eating or
weird angles
and some sequences are resting at home
like this one on the left where I am
doing the New York Times crossword
puzzle uh as I lay on my couch the one
in the middle I'm out grocery shopping
and have my grocery list up and in the
third one I'm doing uh some shopping for
some intimate personal items while I
text one of my friends to see what
they're up to later
other parts of this project might reveal
personal details like here are some
articles that I was reading here's one
that's a little meta where my friend is
uh posting on Instagram about using the
software
uh and another one where my roommate at
the time is asking me about a recent
date
so here are some of them in motion and
in these uh three Clips uh all three of
us are
um
using another device in the background
so like there's another computer being
depicted
and accounting for data I saw lots of
different examples of Biometrics being
used some things that were measurable
some things like one of my absolute
favorite Clips is the one in the middle
here where my friend is brushing her
teeth and she kind of disappears for a
while and then here's like the phone
make a sound and comes back to see
what's going on and in the third one
here Google Maps is up while my friend
drives to another location
so here's what the insulation looked
like with all three videos together
and something that struck me working on
this project was that it wasn't just the
voluntary participants in this work who
were implicated it was also everyone
that we knew from a distance and this is
the nature of our existence online uh so
we it's not possible to opt out of every
single transaction or interaction that
we might have with someone you however
large or small it may be
and the process for filming this piece
was a little different than the one I
had used for the others that I showed
you today so in crafting this piece I
was really careful to let my friends
retain control of their data by letting
them filter out anything that they
didn't want me or the general public to
have access to so all of the recordings
stayed on the devices until my friends
transferred them back to me so they had
an opportunity to delete things that
they didn't want me to have
and in one case I also removed something
from the video that a mutual friend had
asked me to because they were doing some
Community organizing work and didn't
want everyone to know that they were
doing that at the time so
um when they had seen the work up in the
gallery they were like before the before
the show opens can you please remove
that and I did and it's possible that
some people would see this as a weakness
of the work but the goal here wasn't to
just prototype a system of surveillance
and accept all of the harm as a
necessary part of the work I still
wanted to create the work with care and
to tell stories about the impact of
everyday Technologies through a personal
lens
uh so to wrap up this process I
interviewed my friends uh who used the
app and the results were mixed one
friend felt that it made them more wary
of surveillance and the other uh was
really taken by the visual forms that
the work generated and thought of it
more as a new form of camera especially
because I had given her so much control
over what would be shown in the gallery
so I also tried to use the opportunity
to think about where their work might go
next and I asked uh
some questions about sound what what
this would have been like if I had also
recorded sound and the frequency of
recording so here are some of the things
that they had to say
so this question was what if the app had
been had recorded all of the time uh
even when the phone was locked and not
actively being used and so this friend
uh thought this would be
like a little more scary and also that
they would have less control over what
was being shown because they their my
experience using the app was that when I
would pick up the phone I had a moment
to decide like oh do I really want to
unlock this right now do I really want
this moment to be a part of this artwork
and record it forever but if it's
recording all the time it sort of
recedes back into the background of
Everyday Use and some things might be
occurring where you leave the phone on
the table and you're not sure exactly
what it's doing at that time
and uh other friends thought that it
really depended on where the data was
ending up so they were thinking about
their direct experience using the app
and how it had recorded only to their
device and
um and what that would be doing
for sound uh
my friends thought that this was really
interesting because it would be harder
to predict what the results would be
especially if it was recording all the
time
and this is something I'm actually
working on a project related to this
idea right now uh last summer I recorded
24 hours of audio through my phone and
then processed the audio with some
speech to text software and I'm working
on turning the transcript into a
generative book the audio transcripts
are okay
uh because this is a Tech conference
I'll wrap up this talk with a very short
description of my process which I hope
at least some of you will find uh
relatable though I'm not going to go in
depth on it because I don't think it's
particularly remarkable in terms of
building an app
so there are actually two pieces uh to
building these projects on the software
side so one is the Android app itself
which involved automatically capturing
and saving the video from the phone's
front camera back camera and screen uh
whenever the device is unlocked and the
other piece was actually processing all
the videos to turn them into a new
project so for the Android app
uh here's how I felt about my process
for that at the time
I this is from when I was finishing up
this project I wrote that I was getting
a master of Fine Arts in stitching
together Snippets of Android code from
stack Overflow and build so building the
Android app was a process of trial and
error this was the first and actually to
date still only Android app I had ever
built so I spent a lot of time looking
at tutorials from the platform and
reading help articles on which camera
API to use and how to improve the
quality of the recordings and how to
make the recordings appear in the file
server so that I could actually pull
them off the phone which I did not know
for a while was a really important step
and as a part of this process there was
also an occasional assist from friends
who knew the right search term so it
wasn't that they actually like wrote
some of the code for me I would describe
to them what I was trying to do and that
I had
you know tried to rephrase it as many
ways as possible and they would say oh
Android calls that this
and then it would be like oh wow there
are so many articles on this thank you
and this is what the finished capture
app looked like uh it was nothing pretty
just two buttons uh designed mostly to
be used by just me and never intended to
be released in the App Store just for
personal use
so like I said the second piece of
custom software for this project was
actually turning all the videos into the
video that I wanted and it turns out
that there aren't really any programs
available that will just simultaneously
Loop 1100 videos for you uh or at least
I wasn't aware of any in 2016 so I tried
to learn a touch designer thinking that
that would be a really efficient tool to
use and also to learn more about Cinder
which is another creative coding
platform built in C plus plus hoping
that those would let me do things faster
but at the end of the day I got stuck
and fell back on some tools that I knew
really well
so this ended up being a three-step
process first
was cutting all of the 1100 videos for
the first project into single frames for
each one so that I could read them frame
by frame do the layout for a single
frame output a new
image that had all of them laid out
together and then stitched them back to
all of those individual frames back
together into a video and so ffmpeg was
the tool that I used for cutting all the
videos into single frames if there are
any ffmpeg developers watching this talk
thank you you make one of my favorite
open source art tools
uh and the step for doing the layout uh
I actually use processing uh to read all
the image images from a directory uh
calculate how they should be composed
and arranged and then actually save the
layouts the composed image into its own
file and then the last step was asking
ffmpeg one more time to take all of
those images that had been created and
processing and to stitch them back
together into a single video and one
final point of improvement for the third
project was writing a python script to
automate all three of those steps so
they weren't manual which is how they
worked for the first two projects
so it was not a fast or efficient
project but fortunately I'm an artist so
that doesn't really matter
um
uh the thing that matters is that you
show up with the gallery with the work
and uh it got the job done so I just
feel like every once in a while I need
to make a plug for that too
and so while all of these projects
utilize code and Technology I really
want to underscore uh that the work is
not really about building an app the
work is really about the impact of
technology on our bodies and social
relationships and trying to understand
that through a personal narrative
so throughout all of these projects uh
creating software was and continues to
be for me a fundamental part of my
process as an artist it helps me
understand the limits possibilities and
risks of technological systems
thank you so much for listening
yeah so the question was about how I had
mentioned that using this app changed my
habits using the phone and then there
was also a follow-up question did I keep
my house tidier or something like that
as a part of this knowing that it would
show up in the video and I think that
this
some degree the answer is yes and also
mostly no for that one I think for
sometimes like if I had laundry on the
floor and it was like I really don't
want people seeing my dirty clothes I
might think for a second what if I
turned this way just a little bit while
I uh answer this email uh so I think yes
to some degree but it wasn't a deterrent
from like even looking at the device in
quite the same way
yeah sure so the question was uh
what was the choice or was it a
decision-making process like for
um
deciding to use something that was very
uh representational rather than abstract
for
um most of the works and I think that
initially uh the reason to use the video
just as it was was because I didn't know
what I had and I really just wanted to
see what was there for some of the the
later work I didn't want it to be as
directly representational but still
wanted uh
to be able to see some of the work and I
do have another project that I didn't
show today that does some more computer
vision and like processing of the colors
uh that are in the work as a print-based
work so it is uh something that's very
much on my mind for future work
yeah so the question was
um how much was I thinking about like
spyware and malware and who could access
video from that as a part of this
project and I think that that was
certainly on my mind even though it
wasn't something that was like directly
visualized
um
especially for some of the audio work
that I've been doing after that a lot of
what I've been thinking about is when
people kind of report like oh I was just
talking to my friend about this and now
I'm getting ads uh for it so the like
listening aspect uh was something that I
was really interested in kind of
answering like the question for me like
okay well what if someone did get access
to my phone like what would they be able
to see
[Laughter]
yeah this is a really great question so
I'll repeat the question for the
recording uh the question was about uh
if for both me and my friends uh if it
was kind of a similar result having just
the like blank phone face uh staring uh
into the camera and the answer is like
for the most part yes
um with the exception of some moments
where like it's clear that there's
another person present who's being
talked to directly
um
I
I am sure there are like a few Clips
where I kind of giggle at something as
I'm like texting someone or something
like that but there weren't a lot of
those like they're not in every single
clip where a social interaction takes
place
brain
sure so the question is does it make me
feel more aware about like how I might
look in public if I'm being recorded and
I think that the honest answer is is no
that I didn't really think about that a
lot but this question probably will
change that for me
all right thank you all so much uh for
coming to my talk
[Applause]